we are told the population of a town
grows at a rate of e to the 1.2 t power
minus two t people per year where t is
the number of years at t equals two
years the town has fifteen hundred
people
so first they ask us approximately by
how many people does the population grow
between t equals two and t equals five
and then what is the town's population
at t equals five years
and if we actually figure out this first
question the second question is actually
pretty straightforward we figure out the
amount that it grows and then add it to
what we were at at t equals two add it
to fifteen hundred
so pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
so the key here is to appreciate that
this right over here is expressing the
rate of how fast the population is
growing and we've been seeing in
multiple videos now let me just draw do
a quick review
of this notion
of a rate curve
so
those are my axes
and this
is my t-axis my time axis
and so this is showing me how my rate of
change
changes as a function of time
so
let's say it's something like this
so once again if i said at this time
right over here this is my rate this
doesn't tell me for example what my
population is this tells me what is my
rate of change of a population and we
have seen in previous videos that if you
want to figure out the change in the
thing that the rate is met that the rate
is the rate of change of say the change
in population you would find the area
under the rate curve between those two
appropriate times and why does that make
sense well imagine a very small change
in time right over here if you have a
very small change in time and if you
assume that your rate is approximately
constant over that very small change in
time
well then your change in let's say we're
measuring the rate of change of
population here
your accumulation you could say is going
to be your
rate times your change in time which
would be the area of this rectangle and
so that would be the roughly that would
be the area under the curve over that
very very small change in time
so what we really want to do is find the
area under this curve from t equals 2 to
t equals 5. and we have seen multiple
times in calculus how to express that
so
the definite integral from
t is equal to 2 to t is equal to 5
of this expression of
e
to the 1.2 t
minus 2t
dt
dt
so if we just evaluate that that will be
the answer to this first question
so what is this going to be well let's
actually work it out
so what is the antiderivative of e to
the 1.2 t
well let me just try to do it over here
so if i'm trying to calculate
let me write it as e to the five or
actually six fifths t
say 12 tens is the same thing as six
fifths
six fifth t
d t so this is an indefinite integral
i'm just trying to figure out the
anti-derivative here
well if i had a six-fifths right over
here then u-substitution or sometimes
you would say the inverse chain rule
would be very appropriate well we could
put a six-fifth there if we write a
five-six right over here five-sixths
times six-fifths and we can take
constants in and out of the integral
like this scaling constants i should say
well now so this is going to be equal to
5 6 this 5 6 right over here this
anti-derivative is pretty
straightforward since i have the
derivative of 6 fifths t right over here
i can find the antiderivative with
respect to six fifths t which is
essentially i'm doing u substitution if
you had to do u substitution you would
make that right over there u and then
that and that would be your du
but needless to say this would be 5 6
times e to the 6 fifths t and if you're
thinking about the indefinite integral
you would then have a plus c here of
course and you can verify that the
derivative of this is indeed e to the
1.2 t
so this is going to be equal to
so
this part right over here the
anti-derivative is 5 6
e to the six-fifths
t
and then
this part right over here the
anti-derivative of 2t is t squared so
minus
t squared and we are going to evaluate
that
at
5 and 2 and find the difference so let's
evaluate this at when t is equal to 5.
well you are going to let me color code
this a little bit when t
is equal to 5 you get 5 6
times e to the 6 fifths times 5 is e to
the 6th
minus 5 squared so minus 25
and so from that
i want to subtract
when we evaluate
it at
2 we get
5 6
e to the six-fifths times two
is the same thing as twelve fifths or we
could say that's two point four
two point four
minus
four
2 squared is 4.
and so what do we get
well there's a couple of ways that we
could do this so that we could write
this as
let me write it this way we could write
this so we have a 5 6
and a 5 6. so we could write this as 5 6
times
e to the 6th
e to the 6th
minus e to the 2.4
minus because we distribute that
negative sign e to the 2.4
e to the 2.4 power
and then we have
minus 25 let me just send another color
to keep track of it we have minus 25 and
then you have minus
negative 4 so that would be plus 4 so
that would be minus
21
and i would need a calculator to figure
this out so let me do that let me get my
calculator on this computer
and there we go and so let's see if we
want to find
e to the sixth power
that's 430 okay so then now let me
figure out
so
minus i would say
22.4 that looks like a 24 i'll correct
it as soon as i get back to that screen
e to that power
e to the 2.4 power
and i get equals so what's in
parentheses is this number right here so
times 5 6
times 5 divided by 6
is equal to
that
minus 21 minus 21
is equal to this so if i round to the
nearest hundredth it's going to be
approximately 306.00
so this is approximately 306.00
so approximately by how many people does
the population grow between t equals two
and t equals five well by approximately
306 people
let me write that down
so approximately 306 people
and they say what is the town's
population at t equals five
well at time two at two years we had
fifteen hundred people
and then we grow over this interval by
three hundred six so
plus
three hundred and six well that's going
to get me to
deserve a little bit of a drum roll one
1806 people at t equals 5 years